hey let's give them one
a little bit of that how about the
chiefs on three one
two
three
how about those trees
hey hey
one more thing
is
next year we're coming right back here
one more time baby
one more time
that is andy reid yesterday after the uh
parade in kansas city
andy my gosh andy right in the check and
if i didn't know better chris sims if i
didn't know that andy reid isn't a
drinker given his mormon faith i would
think that maybe he had a few yesterday
didn't he seem like he's feeling pretty
good maybe he's just high on life maybe
somebody slipped a little vodka into his
kool-aid i don't know but i i it made me
a little nervous to see him declare that
they're going to be back next year well
yeah you don't you don't ever really
hear that from a head coach to make
those kind of comments but i mean to
what you're saying though andy was
he was feeling it yesterday yeah you're
right high on life euphoria whatever it
was and he was enjoying the moment i
mean really that was really cool to see
the turnout the chiefs fans uh
had for for the whole event but you know
just seeing andy finally being able to
enjoy the glory of winning a super bowl
you know i would have a hard time
thinking that doesn't bring a lot of
smiles to a lot of people's faces around
the nfl because you and i like we've
talked about a lot have been around andy
and they just don't get any more nice
you know personable charismatic
everything about that he really makes
you feel like he knows you and cares
about you whether he does or not i don't
know but he makes me feel that way
and we've gotten ourselves caught up in
this notion that the chiefs are on the
front end of a dynasty but let's reflect
on what happened this year they needed
the patriots to trip over their
shoelaces in week 17 to have a buy yep
they they had to come back from down 24
nothing to the texans they had to come
back from a 10-point deficit twice
against the titans and they had to come
back from 10 points down with six
minutes to play in the super bowl this
is not the 1985 bears level of dominance
where they blew out everyone in the
postseason and route to the super bowl
xx title
this is a team that very easily could
have not won the super bowl why is there
this sense chris that one becomes two
becomes three becomes four for this team
well i that is a good question i think
first off i mean to what you know to
your point
they were more dominant in 2018 than
they were in 2019 as a football team you
know of course it didn't end the same
way with losing to new england in the
afc championship but you know if you go
back and watch i mean that that was that
was unbelievable if you go back and
watch the highlights from two years ago
uh it was something special this year
it was a lot it was winning a lot of
different ways and not always dominant
you know with a whole team effort one
week it was the offense one week was the
defense this week it was special teams
this year they wrote they they found
ways to win a lot of different ways in a
football game and seem more battle
tested maybe than they did last year
where we just felt like oh they're going
to outscore you and that's it
but uh so i i i think we're thinking
that though because we've seen them in
the playoffs for a number of years we
know andy reid's a good coach and of
course the quarterback and the
quarterback has his two main weapons
around him for a little while here and
that's where i think we look at it and
we just go watch out because the
pressure's off and now 15 can just let
it fly and not even worry about anything
anymore
and i really do think that's the key
right getting the super bowl win yes
early in your career joe montana year
three yeah tom brady year two right once
you climb the mountain and realize i can
do this even though you get thrown back
to the valley of zero and zero and have
to climb it again
you know that you can do it you have the
confidence to do it and and we talked
about this earlier in the week
maybe patrick mahomes the next time in
the super bowl won't be kind of tight
early on yes you know not his usual self
maybe he'll slide into that screw it i'm
just gonna go play my game mode because
when he finally did what happened they
came back and won yeah that you're
exactly right he just he refused to let
it go he you know and again it's hard to
let it go when you know you got a great
defense who's flying around and you're
going man if i throw this ball in the
tight window and somebody gets a finger
tip on it ball goes in the air i get an
interception but you know i've watched
the game back three nights in a row not
like in totality but it's been on the
nfl network right and i turn it on and
put it on and my kids are like you're
watching this again why are you so
stupid and i just go i don't know you
know i kind of pick new things up every
time you watch it and yeah he i mean
this is what's amazing this is why we're
saying he they might go back to the
super bowl because
he played one of the worst games of his
career and came back against one of the
best defenses we've seen in 10 years in
past defense and and really one of the
better defenses we've seen in recent
history i think that's where we go he he
didn't even play good and he still did
that are you and are you kidding me i
think that's why we're excited i know
i'm excited and yeah now he's got
nothing right like russell wilson
winning it so early on too i know he
lost it the second year but he was
fearless in that second super bowl too
right drove them down to the one yard
line and he's kind of been fearless ever
since because hey it's off my back i
know i can deliver in the big moments
and i can let it fly
well and
look this isn't what we're here to talk
about but we addressed yesterday
russell wilson's candor uncharacteristic
candor regarding what he'd like on the
roster right telling us last week that
he'd like to play more up tempo
i think we're starting to see the
urgency from him eight years in looking
back on one super bowl win and now
you've got this kid in my homes who have
a second year as a starter has a super
bowl a guy you got to compete with a guy
you're going to cross paths with who's
going to blow by your legacy quickly by
all appearances and yeah winning that
super bowl early should be the path to
multiple championships we haven't seen
it from aaron rodgers now it was weird
because
he was drafted in 2005 won the super
bowl in 2010 but it was his third year
as a starter right for mahomes year two
as a starter wilson year two as a
starter and and here's the real question
chris
mds and i delved into this earlier in
the week on the pft pm super bowl 54
awards podcast what is the over under
on number of championships that will
make patrick mahomes career not a
disappointment yeah how many does it
take how many and a half two and a half
three and a half four and a half what is
it yeah that's a uh
a really good question and
you know i guess from where we're
sitting right now all right yes 2020 his
second year's a story he won a super
bowl
like i look at it and you know i he's
not a disappointment right that's that's
already done like he's not a career
disappointment no no no but i know chris
in all fairness aaron rodgers aaron
rodgers career is a disappointment i get
that russell wilson right now if he
doesn't win another one disappointment
when we see the promise we see the
potential we see who he is we see what
he can do how many does he have to win
for us to say when it's all said and
done he fulfilled the potential in the
promise i mean i would think three i
think three would be like very realistic
i mean really we're being unrealistic by
saying two i mean this is not an easy
thing to achieve we've been scored by
the new england patriots right and the
49ers and the steelers and the quarter
and troy aikman won three i look i i i
don't think it's i don't think it's
unfair
to say what what what is the bar he's
set the bar so high already what is the
bar for his career i think it's three
and a half i think he's got to get four
so you think he's gonna get four i mean
if he gets three we're going to come
away and go man mahomes was special you
won five mv nfl mvps and you know three
super bowls and three super bowl mvps
most likely to go along with that you
know i don't see how you could look at
anybody's career after that and go
that's disappointing you know yes you're
right right now we're sitting here going
man i mean this guy's got as much talent
or more talent than anybody we've ever
seen he could go down in the great as
the greatest player of the game in the
in the history of the game i mean he's
got more talent than a tom brady but now
it's about can he you know accomplish
all the accomplishments that brady
accomplished you like that three
accomplishments for now wow yes in in
his career i mean that's what it really
comes down to is now matching up the
play with some hardware to put you in
that stratosphere of you know you know
gods of football like like uh montana or
brady or terry bradshaw troy eikman like
you're talking about so we'll see where
it goes the other thing mike too just
real interesting you talked about the
russell wilson ankle angle i mean i
would think lamar jackson and deshawn
watson they were watching on sunday
and this this this is going to make that
rivalry better too they're just going to
make them more desperate you know i
would think they were probably sitting
there rooting for jimmy garoppolo
because they were just going i don't
want my homes to get at one yet i want
to get it first you know because they're
all in that age group together where
it's going to be real the competition
there i would think they were sitting at
home going damn this guy he won this
damn super bowl and now i got to get
back to the drawing board and get to
work myself
and patrick mahomes is going to be
competing with some great quarterbacks
let's not forget this is a golden age of
young quarterbacks with kyler murray and
lamar jackson and russell wilson who's
on the wrong side of 30 but still in
that group desean watson and who knows
what joe burrow and tuatanga vilo and
justin herbert are going to become and
sam darnold and josh allen
there's a lot of competition a lot of
competition but here's the thing here's
the thing
tom brady won six championships with
drew brees peyton manning aaron rodgers
brett favre all those guys floating
around so it is possible for someone to
rise up and win all the rings
and and i remember before tom brady
passed montana and bradshaw to get to
number five with super bowl 51 the 28-3
comeback
i i remember before that there wasn't a
consensus on the greatest quarterback of
all time you could argue four or five
different guys once brady got to five
and especially once he got to six i
think it was hard and i know you you say
aaron rodgers but you're in the minority
yeah the the most people say tom brady
what does it take for patrick mahomes to
supplant tom brady does he have to win
more than tom brady or does he just have
to get close
and have all the all-time records and
all those great moments and we're going
to remember him as a better overall
player if he just gets within one or two
of brady it's going to be an interesting
debate that i hope i live long enough to
see yeah right i'm with you there but
yeah i think you're right i think that's
where i think like yeah you know to get
six or seven first of all you know i
just don't know if that's realistic and
whatever you know whatever but
i think if he does get around four if he
gets to that four or five category
and yes the style of which he plays
listen new england wins super bowls
because you know brady dissects you
right the offense is amazing the scheme
is amazing they teach it to brady he can
digest it all and then he can go out
there and execute it and make big throws
it's different in kansas city kansas
city andy china just goes hey you run
this way you run this way patrick drop
back and make it happen just make it
happen okay i'm gonna send people and be
aggressive and you just go that way it's
not surgical moore is on the shoulders
of mahomes to make it happen with just
his great ability and that's where yes i
can even the conversation if he's a
super bowl or too short of brady let
alone it's looking like we're gonna be
on the pace of a guy that's gonna have
you know three four five mvps anywhere
in that category i think that would be
safe to say
but but again you've got lamar jackson
sean watson and and the thing that kept
mahomes from winning a second regular
season mvp although it still may have
been lamar jackson because 1200 plus
rushing yards and 36 touchdown passes
but mahomes injury missed a couple games
wasn't the same when he came back right
that knocked him out of the mvp race he
stays healthy and that's the other thing
too look we've seen two seasons out of
him he was injured and missed a couple
of games and it took him a while to get
back to 100 percent can he stay healthy
on a consistent basis that's the one
thing about quarterbacks that we take
for granted and overlook that ability to
play yeah every week every week every
week like a dak prescott has done
through four years of his career like
tom brady has done every year of his
career except
2008 when he had the torn acl durability
and ability to play at a high level
every week is something we shouldn't
take for granted no you're right and
especially with guys like like this you
know this is what to me is amazing about
brett favre but like rogers and mahomes
i think it's
especially there be in that conversation
because they have to they play a game
that's so close to the edge right i mean
it's you know every play is oh there's a
guy on my shoulder oh i made a spin move
oh i'm throwing the ball as three guys
are about to crush me but i still threw
a 30-yard laser down the field because
of the way they play and what they're
asked to do they have to tote the line
of danger a little bit more than maybe
let's say a peyton manning or a tom
brady because they were more of the
pocket passing type player there
so yes yeah i think that's a valid point
because he's a freaky athlete and a
freaky player he never gives up on a
play which can yes put himself in danger
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports